scarlett johansson and colin jost have
welcomed their first child together a
baby boy they've named cosmo
why is she the one for you miss scarlett
johansson
well she's you know she's pretty cool
the snl comedian took to instagram to
confirm the news on wednesday sharing
these two messages first he wrote okay
okay we had a baby his name is cosmo we
love him very much and then privacy
would be greatly appreciated at this
time i'm committed that's pretty
exciting jost followed up with a joke
involving his weekend update co-host
saying quote for all inquiries please
contact michael che this is the second
child for scarjo she shares six-year-old
daughter rose with ex-husband romaine
dariac being a working mom is
is it's incredible it's an incredible
challenge it's an incredible gift the
marvel star opened up to e.t about
balancing a hectic schedule all while
being a working mom you're at work you
feel like you're missing out on those
special moments with your kid if you're
with your kid you feel like you're not
giving enough to your job have a lot of
like huge admiration and respect for
working moms
is calling a fan now was he a fan before
um
yeah i think he's a he i gotta ask him
yeah that's important to know actually
scarlett has hosted saturday night live
many times over the years and it's even
where she ended up meeting her future
husband the couple got engaged in 2019
after two years of dating yeah wedding
planning that's a thing you're supposed
to do
it doesn't just happen they tied the
knot the following year in an intimate
ceremony sharing the news with this
funny image posted to social media
scarlett has also shared with e.t what
it meant to have colin by her side
during the pandemic it's been a time
where
all of us have
been able to
step back and just reflect on what's
most important you know i think when you
can
get through what we've all been through
this past you know year and a half and
you come out the other side and you're
you're like okay you're the person you
want here in the we're in the foxhole
you know and we did it you know that's
really significant
[Music]